[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: Hello, my
name is Bruno Oliveira,
and I'm an engineer in
the Play Games team.
And in today's
"Dev.Bytes" episode
we're going to talk about
a problem that comes up
very often in multiplayer games.
And that is, of course, how
do you choose who goes first?
Remember that multiplayer
is symmetrical.
So no one is naturally special.
There is no server or
anything like that,
but sometimes, you need to
choose one of the players
to have a special role, like
to be the judge of a match,
to make the first
movie, or you need
to decide who's player one,
who's player two, and so on.
So how do you do this?
Your first thought
looking at the API
may be, oh, let me use
the room's creator.
So the player who is
the creator of the room
is going to be the
judge or is going
to make the first
move, et cetera.
That's generally a bad idea.
That's a bad idea,
because there's
a funny thing that happens in
automatch, because automatch
really means we got a
whole bunch of rooms
and put them together
into a single room.
So when you have automatch
players in the room,
there will not
necessarily be agreement
on who was the room's creator.
So that doesn't
work as expected.
So you may think, OK, I'm
going to use the player ID.
Right, so everyone
has a player ID.
I'm just going to
sort the player IDs,
and whoever has
the lowest player
ID is going to be
the first to play.
Again, that's a bad
idea, because when
you have automatch players,
you don't have access
to the player IDs of
those automatched players.
So that method
doesn't work either.
OK.
What if you just
used participant IDs.
That's a slightly better
idea, because everyone
has a participant ID.
However, that's
still not very good.
And why?
OK.
Let's suppose you're
doing something like this.
So you got everyone's
participant IDs,
which are these funny strings.
You sort that list, and then
you pick that first player
on that list to start the
game, or to be the king,
or to have that special role.
Sure, that works, and
definitely everyone's
going to agree on who
has that special role.
But here's the problem.
A participant ID is not
really a random string.
It actually has some
structure to it.
It's encoded information.
So suppose that I'm that
last guy over there,
and I'm unlucky enough that in
every single match that I play,
my participant ID
begins with a Z.
So if I'm unlucky enough
that that happens,
then no matter how
many matches I play,
I'll never get to play first.
I'll never get to be the king.
I'll never get that
special role in the game.
So the game might be
very boring for me.
So we definitely don't
want that to happen.
So one of the ways you can
solve that problem is you
sort the list of
participant IDs as before.
Then you pick the first
player on that list,
but that player's not going
to play the special role.
His only responsibility
is going to be
to randomly choose who's
going to be the king
or to play first.
After choosing that using
some sort of fair method,
all they have to do is then
broadcast to the other players
that selection.
And then everyone's
going to agree
that player is going to
be the king or the leader,
and the choice was fair.
So no one had the privilege
of being the king many times.
And then everyone agrees,
and now all we have to hope
is that F029 is going to
be a wise ruler that's
going to lead your game into
an age of peace and prosperity.
That was it for
today's "Dev.Bytes."
Thank you.